. Das Intro hat Flo und die mir gerade angekündigt mit, das muss auch mal dringend raus. Der muss dringend weg. Der muss, der liegt jetzt schon seit Wochen auf der Fensterbank, langsam gehen die Ränder so nach oben. Das muss langsam weg. Vielen Dank an Valentin für dieses fantastische Intro. Danke Valentin. Aber wo du gerade von Rändern sprichst, man sagt ja, Käse schwitzt. Ich dachte immer, das wäre so ein ungesprachlicher Ausdruck dafür, dass Käse irgendwann einfach weg muss. Ja. Aber er schwitzt tatsächlich wirklich. Aus Angst, oder was? Nee, er schwitzt, das sieht einfach aus, da bewiesen sich dann einfach so Feuchtigkeitströpfchen. Das sieht aus, als hätte er kurz, wäre er ein Fiddy gewesen und hätte ein paar Sachen gedrückt. Vor allem manche Sachen werden mit der Zeit weich, wie Schokolade oder Käse, manche werden hart, wie andere Arten von Käse. Milch wird Käse, nach einiger Zeit. Ja, und Sahne wird Schlagsahne. Was ist da los? Und Weintrauben werden Wein. Was? Ja, wenn man Saft sehr lange stehen lässt, werden daraus Kulturen. Ja, muss man sagen, so Schimmelkulturen. Oh, ich habe jetzt im Heimathaus Schimmel. Was? Ja. Hast du ein paar Schimmeltipps, Stefan Schimmeltipps? Die Top 20 Stefan Schimmeltipps auf Platz 20. Brottrunk tatsächlich. Auf Platz 20 ist Brottrunk. Auf Platz 19. Das ist die einzige Sache, die mir mein Bio-Lehrer... Auf Platz 18!
Wir haben das voraufgezeichnet.
Auf Platz 17!
Kein Muss mich da anhalten. Eigenurin.
Auf Platz 16! Wieso Eigenurin eigentlich?
Ist nicht alles von irgendwem als Eigenurin?
Es kommt darauf an, ob du dein eigenes Urin trinkst
oder das von anderen Menschen und oder Tieren.
Ich möchte da gar nicht werten.
Eigenblut hilft auch
gegen vieles, sagt man ja. Eigenblut hilft auch gegen Allergien, habe ich jetzt gehört. Ich glaube, es ist generell ein schlechtes Zeichen, wenn du überhaupt Eigenblut zur Verfügung hast. Ich glaube, dann ist es eh schon zu spät. Also vielleicht ist es dann noch ein heilender... Ich glaube, du kannst Blut nicht einfach trinken, um es wieder dem Körper zuzufügen. Vor allem Eigenblut, ich dachte, das macht man raus, dann macht man es irgendwann wieder rein, aber es kommt dann in so eine Zentrifuge und dann macht man es wieder rein.
Es wirkt so, als hätte der Arzt ein lustiges Experiment
vorbereitet und der mag einfach Zentrifugen.
Und dann kommt das Blut da kurz rein
und dann fragt man so, hat das irgendeinen Sinn?
Und dann sagt er, nee, ich finde nur Zentrifugen
cool. Zentrifugen
sind auch cool. Ja, objektiv cool.
Vor allem ist es nicht so, dass die Zentrifugalkraft
eigentlich anders heißt, dass die eigentlich
Zentripitalkraft heißt? Pet die eigentlich Zentripitalkraft heißt?
Petal, ja.
Petal.
Zentripitalkraft.
Dass die irgendwie die eine ist, bedeutet, dass es vom Zentrum wegstrebt und die andere keine Ahnung. Petal. Ich höre schon dieses raschelnde Geräusch. Hörst du das auch? Augenrollen? Nee, dieses Leute, die Mails schreiben. Mittlerweile sind wir so konditioniert darauf, dass wenn wir Bullshit erzählen, immer so, man hört die in der Ferne, so diese Armee von Besserwissern, die sofort zur Mail greift und dann kriegen wir wieder 80 Mails rein. Und dann muss man wieder zurückschreiben, danke, aber es war ein Gag, danke, aber es war ein Gag, danke, aber es war ein Gag. Das ist mittlerweile unsere Signatur einfach, die automatisch auf jede Mail kommt. Ja, und dann immer mit dem Satz, ich schreibe ja sonst nicht an Podcasts, aber, und dann kommt die Erklärung, wo ich mir auch denke, das kann statistisch schon gar nicht mehr sein. Und ich sehe im Verlauf, dass sie uns schon mal geschrieben haben. Ja. Das sieht man ganz gut. Was soll das heißen, dieser Anfang, dieses, ich mach das ja sonst nie, aber zeigt direkt mal, okay, du bist was Besseres als ich, du bist straight was Besseres und wir haben richtig Scheiße gemacht. Das heißt jetzt noch auf Deutsch. Es heißt tatsächlich aber Zentripetalkraft, du hast völlig recht. Ich habe dreimal dich korrigiert und lag dreimal selbstbewusst. Das sind drei Punkte Minus für Staffan Tietze. Minus drei Punkte. Ich glaube, das ist aber wirklich die Kraft, die es gibt. Und die Zentrifugakraft, die existiert gar nicht. Das ist eine Scheinkraft, weil die dagegen wirkt, ist gegen das andere. Aber er nagelt mich darauf nicht fest. Ich habe Schimmel... Ja immer noch die Physikklausuren geschrieben. Aber nageln Sie mich nicht darauf fest. Ich glaube, das reicht. Da kriegst du automatisch bessere Noten. Ich glaube, tatsächlich ursprünglich hat ja Einstein gesagt, ist gleich im C-Quadrat, aber hundertprozentig bin ich mir auch nicht sicher. Eigentlich sind das Ungefährzeichen gemacht. Ich liebe das Ungefährzeichen. Was hat das für eine Existenzberechtigung in der Mathematik? Vor allem, wie groß ist die Spannweite? Kann man einfach in der Klausur jedes Mal ungefähr? Wie undäufig muss dann ein Gleichheitszeichen sein, wie es auch ein Ungefährzeichen sein könnte? Vor allem, es ist einfach das Deppensymbol. Einfach das Symbol, das eingeführt wurde, damit Vollidioten auch noch einen halben Punkt kriegen können. Das ist nie falsch. Zwei plus drei ist ungefähr vier.
Ich würde sagen, ja, es ist ja nicht
falsch, diese Aussage. Es ist fast
vier.
Wie in der Mathe-Geometrie-Klausur
war irgendwie diese Frage,
du bist 200 Meter von einem
Heißluftballon entfernt, von dem
Startpunkt des Heißluftballons,
und du misst von deiner Position
einen 40-Grad-Winkel auf die Position des Heißluftballons. Also kann man sich vorstellen. 300 Meter, 40 Grad aus deiner Position. Ich denke mir, easy, easy. Rechne, Sinus, Cosinus, Tangenz, kein Problem, Ergebnis 1,7 cm ist der Luftballon hoch. Und ich schreibe das so hin und wollte wirklich so hinzufügen, mir ist durchaus bewusst, dass das falsch ist,
aber so ist halt Mathe, Kollege.
Man kann es sich nicht aussuchen.
Und man gibt das ab, man gibt diese Arbeit ab und mit diesem,
ja, ich bin Trottel und hier ist es einfach der Beweis.
Ich bin vollidiot, bitteschön.
Ungefähr 1,7.
Aber tatsächlich, ich frage mich, wer sich diese Beispiele ausdenkt, weil wer ist gerade, man ist doch aufgeregt vor einem Heißluftballonflug. Da will man doch nicht noch messen, wie hoch der jetzt ist. Ja, vor allem ein Heißluftballon wird nie gerade nach oben fliegen, das wirst du selber wissen. Nee, stimmt. Von daher ist es schwierig, aber ich glaube, das ist auch so. Es gibt auch so sich selbst nicht so ernst nebene Matheaufgaben, vielleicht so ein Text drinsteht wie, Florian, die musst du in einer Klausur herausfinden, wie hoch das entfernt ist. So eine Metaschulaufgabe. Ja, so eine Metaschulaufgabe. Das ist schwierig zu erklären. Aber ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen der Versuch, so ein bisschen Realitätsnähe in so Klausuren hinzubringen. Das klappt bis zu einer gewissen Altersstufe. Ich glaube, bis Altersstufe siebte Klasse klappt das. Ab dann ist einfach Elektronenkanone und dann so, Lenny hat eine Elektronenkanone und schiesst damit Ehoch 28 Elektronen auf die Goldspule von Nina. Wie viel Energie kommt an der Goldspule von Nina an? Das ist Euphemismus für Sex eigentlich. Ich habe eine Erektion, ich kann nicht denken. Pack deine Elektronenkanone ein, Erik!
Piu, piu, piu, piu!
Oh Mann.
Aber leider muss man sagen, ja, es ist schon die Idee,
Realitätsaufgaben zu machen, aber leider halt von Leuten,
die offensichtlich professionelle Heistup-Ballonfahrer sind.
Meistens.
Jeder lebt ja in einer anderen Realität.
Was für den einen realistisch wirkt, kann für den anderen völlig abwegig sein.
Ja, das stimmt schon. Ich habe Schimmelflecken tatsächlich einmal in meinem Leben bekämpft, und zwar mit Wodka. Auf Platz 23, Wodka. Ja, ich habe Wodka, schönen Lappen Wodka und damit abgewischt. Hat auch gut geklappt. Hat danach gesungen und war gut drauf, der Schimmel. Hat tatsächlich, danach hat man immer noch, weil der Schimmel nur auf den Bahnen meines Lappens eliminiert wurde, aber nicht an den anderen Stellen, hat man Jahrzehnte danach noch gesehen, genau wie ich gewischt habe.
Weil da, wo ich gewischt habe, kam nie wieder Schimmel, aber außenrum schon. Und dadurch hat sich so diese Zackenkontur von meiner Wischbewegung abgezeichnet.
Ah, Schimmelart.
Also Schimmel, eigentlich im Grunde Schimmelart.
Schimmel-Streetart.
Im Grunde ist es das. Für sie nicht so schlecht. Aber es ist ein Problem, was häufiger vorkommt, Schimmelart. Also Schimmel, eigentlich im Grunde Schimmelart. Schimmel-Streetart. Im Grunde ist es das. Für die Nische ist es schlecht. Aber es ist ein Problem, das häufiger vorkommt, Schimmel. Was sind so Haushaltsprobleme, so typische Haushaltsprobleme, mit denen man sich mal rumschlagen muss, die man eigentlich nicht will? Ja, so Kalk. Immer das Kalk. Was ist Kalk? Kalk. Das ist so an... Das macht das Wasser hart. Wie viele verschiedene Reiniger hast du? Fangen wir mal so an.
Also Laminatreiniger, Glasreiniger.
Das ist ein Glasreiniger?
Nee, du hast ja nie ein Glas.
Klar für Glas.
Ach so.
Für Glas und klarer Flächen.
Ich habe eine WC-Ente mit diesem geschwungenen Hals.
Ich denke, das ist genial.
Ja, ja.
Ich finde das so genial, wenn sie die Verpackung an den Zweck angleicht. Aber es ist keine Ente, es ist ein Schwan. Ja, es ist ein Schwan, das ist genial. Ich finde das so genial, wenn sie die Verpackung an den Zweck angleicht.
Aber es ist keine Ente, es ist ein Schwan.
Ja, es ist ein Schwan, das stimmt schon.
Vor allem, also ich meine...
Hatte ihr meine Ente gesehen, WC-Ente?
Ich mache das...
Komm, den schreibe ich jetzt.
Ente, klar, wegen Schnabel.
Aber das ist ja gar nicht der Gag, den die Flasche macht.
Die Flasche macht den Hals-Gag.
Aber Ente hat den kürzesten Hals von allen Tieren der Welt. Das heißt WC-Schwan. Das ist völlig richtig und den schreiben wir jetzt in der Mail. Jetzt reicht es auch. Jetzt ist wirklich eine Frechheit. So, WC-Ente. Schreibt den Tweet. Schreibt ihn mal einfach an, Freunde. Das ist keine Ente, das ist ein Schwan. Die haben leider keinen Twitter-Account, habe ich gerade gecheckt. Habe ich aber auch kurz geärgert, aber mich selber, dass ich überhaupt in eine Bewegung gezogen habe, dass WC-Ent ein Account hat. Wie heißen denn die Kapitalistentreiber dahinter, die da hinten stehen? So, wie heißen die Leute? WC-Ente. Da ist von Johnson & Son. Cooler Name. Johnson & Son and Coworkers and Lydia. A Family Company. Das ist deren Slogan. SC Johnson & Son, A family company. Das hätte man sich, das ist ja deren Slogan. S.C. Johnson & Son, a family company. Ist ein bisschen redundant. Aber du kannst herstellen, was du willst. Das ist das Gute. Ich glaube, es ist gut, wenn du dir mögliche Märkte offen lässt. So, Kontakt. Letzte Woche Aids, diese Woche WC-Einte. Stück für Stück, man muss sich den Problem der Welt auch für nicht Stück für Stück... Von unten her.
Dem wir jetzt endlich mal dieses Aids-Moloch abgeworfen haben, endlich da raussehen. Anrede her.
Herr.
Sehr geehrter Herr Johnson.
Nachname Will.
Postfachen Dickenstein.
Ich bin stocksauer!
Erstmal aber nett anfangen, sehr geehrte, ist immer gut, wenn man erst dann sehr geehrte Damen und Herren schreibt und dann aber direkt mit einer Beleidigung folgt. Wir sind, oder fangen an, wenn Sie Stocksauer. Seit Jahren benutze ich Ihre WC-Ente mit grossem Erfolg und Genuss. Ich bin gut, das ist so cholerisch, erst nett anfangen und dann immer sich in Rage wehnen. Das muss sein wie so ein gutes Dessert, das gut anfängt und besser aufhört, wo unten dann noch irgendwie so ein Keks ist oder so, wo du dich daran abarbeitest. Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, seit Jahren nutze ich ihr Produkt, die WC-Ente, mit viel Erfolg und Genuss. Immer wieder haben sie sich gegen... Das klingt, als würden wir das trinken. Ich glaube nicht, dass wenige Leute da hinschreiben, die tatsächlich das Zeug trinken. Was passiert? Ein Kumpel von mir hat das getrunken. Hat das immer wieder hat es sich gegen ihre minderwertigen Konkurrenten durchgesetzt und somit einen Platz in meinem Bad und meinem Herzen ergattert. Hat sich ihr Produkt gegen die Konkurrenz, aber jetzt muss man ehrlich sein, durchgesetzt, in Klammern, ausser einmal die zwei Wochen Griechenland, da bin ich schwach geworden und kannte das griechische Wort für Ente. In Klammern schreiben, was das griechische Wort für Ente ist. In Klammern, jetzt bin ich klüger, Doppelpunkt. Klar, Ente, Griechisch. Jetzt, das wird mir Bestellung aufgeben. Das Wort griechische Ente. Papier. Papier. Jetzt bin ich klüger, Papier. Klammer in Klammern. Jetzt bin ich klüger. Klammer in Klammern. Papier. Nicht. So, Klammer zu, Klammer zu, Doppelklammer zu. Ja, ist eine Gleichung jetzt, die Mail. Damit hat sich Eigentlich sollte ich glücklich und zufrieden sein. Damit hat sich ihr Produkt einen Platz in meinem Badezimmer und meinem Herzen ergattert. Eigentlich sollte ich damit glücklich sein. Jetzt wird es wütend. Es kommt so ein Umsprung, wo man denkt, dazwischen ist ... Man hat sich das jetzt gespeichert, die Mail, im Entwurferordner, hat jetzt eine scheiß Woche und hat jetzt weitergeschrieben, der Mail. So muss es klingen. Damit glücklich sein? Doch. Jetzt ist es doch schon in Capitals. Doch. Doch, es gibt ein Detail. Doch, doch. Es ist uns jetzt aufgefallen. Doch. Das ist doch schon in Capitals. Doch. Doch, es gibt ein Detail. Doch, mir ist uns jetzt aufgefallen. Mir ist jetzt ein Detail aufgefallen. Eigentlich besser, wenn der da schon ewig mit sich rumträgt. Doch, es gibt ein Detail. Das mich nie losgelassen hat. Das mich seit jeher beschäftigt. Seit Die hier beschäftigt.
Und jetzt nur noch wütend.
Wie kann es sein,
alles Caps jetzt,
wie kann es sein,
und rot,
dass sie ihr Produkt so erfolgreich als WC-Ente
vermarkten, dennoch
als
Kopfform,
die eines Schwans nutzen.
Das ist das Problem, was man natürlich kennt.
Weil leider ist jetzt, ich mache auch extra Äscherefehler drin, damit es aussieht, als hätte ich daran schneller geschrieben.
Damit es wie ein authentischer WC-Enten-Nutzer aussieht.
Das Problem ist jetzt, jetzt will ich das WC-Ente natürlich irgendwie in den Vordergrund rücken.
Ich schreibe aber schon die ganze Zeit in Caps.
Also mache ich jetzt Sternchen, Ausrufezeichen, Ente, Ausrufezeichen. So machen es die Spanier. Vermarkten. Ist jedoch offensichtlich, da mache ich jetzt zwischen jedem Buchstaben ein Leerzeichen. Machen Ausrufezeichen zwischen jedem Buchstaben. Unleserlich lohnt die ... Offensichtlich ...
Wobei wir es doch offensichtlich mit einem ...
Schwanenkopf zu tun haben.
Ich frage, wie kann das sein?
Ich frage Sie.
Und damit meine ich Sie.
Wie?
Immer wieder klarstellt, mit wem man recht ...
Wie kann das sein? Und das sage ich Ihnen! Ach so. Das ist eine Mail. Also ich habe es geschrieben. So, ich lese es nochmal vor. Das ist wirklich eine Mail, die wir abschicken. Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, seit Jahren nutze ich ihr Produkt, die WC-Ente, mit viel Erfolg und Genuss. Immer wieder hat sich ihr Produkt gegen die Konkurrenz durchgesetzt, außer einmal die zwei Wochen Griechenland, da bin ich schwach geworden und kann das griechische Wort verente. Jetzt bin ich klüger, Barbier nicht.
Doppelklammer zu. Damit hat sich ihr Produkt einen Platz in meinem Badezimmer und meinem Herzen verdient. Eigentlich sollte ich damit glücklich sein. Doch es gibt einen Detail, das mich seit jeher beschäftigt. Wie kann es sein, dass ihr ihr Produkt so erfolgreich als WC-Ente vermarkten, wie es jedoch offensichtlich mit einem Schwan-Kopf
zu tun haben. Ich frage, wie kann das sein? Wo ist der Schnabel? Haben Sie mal eine Ente gesehen? Die Enten haben extrem kurze Hälse. Haben Sie mal eine Ente gesehen, wie hier umsprachlich plötzlich? Nennente? Haben Sie mal eine Ente gesehen, die haben Sie Lappen!
Sie haben die kürzesten, in Klammern, Ausrufezeichen, Hälse, Sie. Und wo ist der Schnabel? Und wo ist der Schnabel? Ich frage, wie kann das sein? Und damit meine ich Sie, wie, wie kann das sein? Mit freundlichen Grüßen, familiischen.. So ein süßer Name. Familie Günther aus Schwerin. Und dann hast du ein Bild unserer glücklichen Familie. Ich neulich, ich Günther. Aus dem schönen Schwerin, aus dem sonnigen Schwerin. Familie Günther aus dem sonnigen. Ich muss aber Köln schreiben, weil ich unsere Adresse geschrieben habe. Aus dem sonnigen Köln. Aus dem warmen Köln. Ach, das Problem ist, ich muss eine echte E-Mail-Adresse angeben. Nehmen wir die Zentrale. Ja, das ist sehr unauffällig. Podcast-Uvo.fail. Nee, wir müssen eine echte Adresse nehmen. Da muss ich jetzt meinen Familiennamen nehmen. Ey, du. Du hast gesagt, du bist bereit, für die WC-Entülle über Leichen zu gehen. Noch hast du das Versprechen nicht angezahlt. Geburtsdatum muss ich auch noch eingeben. Offensichtlich muss man 18 sein, um mit denen zu schreiben. Aber mach dich ein bisschen älter, oder? Ja. Aber nicht zu alt, dass es so Grumpy Old Man ist. Nee, nee, so eine ... 76 sowas. Nee, das ist viel zu alt. Ja? So eine 41 oder sowas. So ein aufstrebender junger Vater, der guten ... Nee, ich meine, 1976 geboren. Ach so. Ich rechne das nicht rückwärts. Ja, was heißt das denn? Betreff, du kannst auswählen zwischen Anerkennung ... Und Hass. Anliegen oder Beschwerde. Allgemeine Frage, Produktvorschlag, wo kann man Produkte kaufen? Andere, Anliegen oder Beschwerde. Produktvorschlag. So, und jetzt muss ich hier... WC Löwe. Das kann man die WC-Ente nicht auswählen, andere. Beschwerde. Ja, Anliegen oder Beschwerde, genau. So, Capture. Was ist denn da los? Wie viel Hass kriegen die denn jeden Tag, dass sie das richtig jetzt bestimmt haben? So, jetzt muss ich noch die Bilder auswählen, wo Busse darauf abgebildet sind. Das ist auch das Neue, dass man da jetzt wirklich so eine Art IQ-Test bewältigen muss. Ja, aber das ist ja genial, weil du kannst ja da auswählen, was du möchtest. Das ist immer richtig, weil die nutzen dich ja als Sortiermaschine bei diesen Busbildern. Ah, okay. Und Google will einfach nur wissen, wo Busse ... Google hat wirklich Interesse daran zu wissen, wo Busse zu sehen. Du kannst ja auch eingeben, was du möchtest, das ist immer richtig. Die hatten ja auch lange diese Wörter, dass sie so bei Büchern, die sie gescannt haben, wo der Algorithmus oder das Programm, ich habe gehört, wir benutzen das Wort Algorithmus zu inflationär, eingesetzt werden. Wenn die das nicht lesen können, dann geben die das da rein und dann kannst du das da reinschreiben. Deswegen benutzen Trolle, gibt es Trollvereinigungen, die da immer irgendwelche unflätigen Wörter reinschreiben, um die Algorithmen zu verwirren. So. Ich glaube, heute machen wir das nicht, weil da machen das irgendwelche Pakistanis oder sowas. Vielen Dank für Ihre Nachricht. Wir bieten uns innerhalb von drei Geschäftstagen zu antworten.
Wir können auch anrufen. Machen wir das nächste Mal, wenn ihr keine Antwort habt.
Sehr gut. Ey, wenn wir in einer Woche keine Antwort haben, dann wird ihr mal den Tatsang geschaffen.
Und dann müssen wir es rausschneiden, weil sie keine Berechtigung erteilt.
Ja, Datenschutzgesetz, ne? Datenschutzwahnsinn, sag ich ja immer. Datenschutzabsurdität.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich hätte lieber, dass die alle meine Daten haben, als dass sie so viele Mails bekommen die ganze Zeit. Das war schon eine harte Woche. Warum muss man sich Datenschutz immer durch so Nervereien erarbeiten? Weißt du, ich glaube, politischer Fortschritt kam noch nie auf die Kosten von Nerven. So dieses Nervige einfach so. Leute haben die Bastille gestürmt,
die haben den Kaiser aus dem Palast gezogen und den
Kopf abgehackt, die haben die Berliner Mauer
gestürzt, ja, die haben irgendwie
Flugblätter geworfen, aber diese
30 E-Mails, das ist,
damit brichst du jeden politischen
Aktivismus, dass du einfach sagst, okay,
Datenschutz, gut, dann hab das Datenschutz, 50 Mails, also
ne, ne, komm. Weißt du, ich hab kein
Problem damit irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendwo Hungerstreik im Wald. Mache ich jeden Tag, kein Stress. Aber dann immer dieses Generve so. Ich glaube, Leute wollen lieber Schmerz als genervt werden. Nerven ist so, ach, das war doch auch locker so ein Politiker, der gesagt hat, ja, okay, dann bekommt euer Datenschutz-Ding. Könnt ihr mal sehen, wie cool ihr das findet. Ihr habt die 800 Mails von Newslettern, von denen ihr nicht mehr wusstet, was für eine Firma dahinter steckt. Aber vor allem, also ich glaube, die löschen ja auch manche Accounts, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich kenne mich wirklich nicht mehr mit aus. Aber einerseits gut ist ja so ein digitaler Sommerputz, also du kriegst dann von deinen 500 Accounts. Ja, du bist von allen Newslettern abgebildet automatisch jetzt, oder? Genau, und du schickst halt dann an die, die du benutst dann an die fünf Dienste, die du benutzt, schickst es hin und der Rest wird gelöscht. Das heißt, ich bin jetzt relativ bald raus aus dem Anglerforum, weil ich mich jetzt dazu entschieden habe, mich nicht mehr zu posten, weil es sinnlose Diskussionen noch geworden ist, weil die Leute gar keine Ahnung haben, wovon sie reden. Und es nervt mich mittlerweile nur noch ... Und goodbye Filmfehlerforum. Ja, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, da bleibe ich weiterhin aktiv. Das ist klar. Filmfehlerforum sind die einzigen, die mir zum Geburtstag gratulieren, okay? Und da bleibe ich auch dabei. Und die Weihnachtskarte ist auch schön. Ja, ist immer schön. Wer steht Weihnachtskarten? Ich habe auch nie Weihnachtskarten verschickt. Aber das ist auch, glaube ich, eher so ein amerikanisches Ding, ne? Karten generell, ne? Also auch diese mit dem, mit der Melodie drin oder sowas? Die sind wunderbar. Musik im Papier? Musik im Papier? Esspapier? Warum sind Leute so scharf auf Papier? Es ist nicht das Spannendste. Ich würde lieber in Schrank essen. Die Leute sagen, Bücher und Papier stirbt, aber es ist falsch. Es ist eine Transformation. Ich würde sagen, Print stirbt, ja, Print auf Esspapier. Hat da mal jemand darüber nachgedacht? Gibt es ein Buch, das komplett auf Esspapier gedruckt wurde? Das war die erste Idee, es war vor Buchdruck. Davor war noch Esspapier, aber das war dann, Leute hatten glaube ich mehr Hunger als Wissensdurst. Aber dürfte man das in der Buchhandlung verkaufen? Dann ne, ne? Buchpreisbindung. Ja, wird ja bald abgelöst, ne? Stimmt, gab es eine Diskussion. Skandal. Das ist aber echt, das wird glaube ich echt ein Problem. Buchpreisbindung wird gelöst, dann haben wir echt ein Problem mit der Buchbranche. Ist das ein Markt, der offensichtlich, das habe ich mir nie bewusst gemacht, nicht auf Angebot und Nachfrage basiert, sondern auf der Buchpreisbindung? Ja, aufgrund des Kulturguts Buch. Aber hier die drecksneoliberalen Kapitalisten in Brüssel sagen mir, da ist mir scheißegal, Herr Kulturgut, ich will Cash, Cash, Cash. Und mehr Brüssel. Brüssel ist einfach auch das beste Wort der Welt. Sorry, aber Brüssel ist einfach ein lustiges Wort. Ich kann die Leute nicht ernst nehmen, die auf die Straße gehen und gegen Brüssel demonstrieren. Naja, aber Französisch Bruges. Bruges, perfekt. Brüssel ist die beste Stadt. Bruges. Brüssel, ich mag auch Genf. Ich mag diese ganzen internationalen Genfer Konventionen.
Das hat irgendwie so eine Gravitas.
Stimmt. Aber warum
sind das immer die Städte, wo ein Buchstabe
anders ist als ein Wort, was man schon kennt?
Brüssel, Genf,
Genf,
Senf, Mitzel.
Ja, es ist immer schon komisch.
Was gibt es noch für Konventionen? Lissabon,
Vertrag von Lissabon?
Lass uns die Ja, Mitzel. Ja, es ist immer... Stimmt schon, ja. Schon komisch. Was gibt es noch für Konventionen? Lissabon, Vertrag von Lissabon. Litterbon. Das ist alles offensichtlich ein Muster. Die Vereinigte Kraft von Litauen, Bonn und Lissabon. Litterbon! Ich meine, irgendwann müssen sich ja Städte zusammenlegen, oder? Werden Städte größer? Ich bin gespannt, wann es die erste Stadt gibt, das ist, glaube ich, dann eher der Trend, in den es geht, der eine Firma. Wenn eine Firma so viel, und das ist ja teilweise schon, wenn man Richtung Wolfsburg. Aber Silicon Valley oder so gibt es das doch auch schon, oder? Die sind ja mehrere Firmen. Ich glaube, vor allem das VW-Gelände, die Fabrik in Wolfsburg, ist ja die größte zusammenhängende Fabrik der Welt. Wow. Ja, und das ist ja fast schon eine Stadt, die ja nur wirklich dann am Reisbrett entstanden ist für VW, wo man sagen könnte, man könnte die Stadt auch Volkswagen-Stadt nennen können. Ja. Und das ist, glaube ich, der Trend, in den es geht. So Apple Campus, Google Campus, das wird, glaube ich, das wird sich so ausbreiten, dass es irgendwann so Städte werden. Das ist schon cool. Manchmal haben Sachen coole Namen und manchmal nicht irgendwie. Das ist so, oft so Verträge werden oft einfach nach der Stadt benannt, in der sie sind, aber oft auch nicht. Manchmal gibt es diesen 2-plus-4-Vertrag oder irgendwie dann den Marshallplan. Das sind coole Namen. Ich weiß nicht, wir bräuchten so eine Namensbehörde, die einfach immer sagt so, pass auf, wollt ihr unterschreiben, cool, aber lass uns nochmal kurz über Namen nachdenken. Ja, und die können auch gleich mitbestimmen wie sowas mit MeToo oder sowas. Ja, oder genau so dieses Je suis, das wird auch langsam nervig. Oder Brayford, das gibt mir auf die Nerven. Gate, Gosling, Gate. Ey, wirklich, Watergate war cool. Und seitdem heißt alles Gate. So, das ist total nervig. Gosling, Gate, was mit Ryan? Gab's das nicht? Hast du gerade Gosling, Gate gesagt? Was ist mit, was ist passiert? Ne, das war doch die Halligalli-Aktion. Ach so. Ja, da muss man auch eine Namenskonvention her. Bill Gates? Das Gates-Gate. Das Gates-Gate. Spätestens da bricht zusammen. Bill Gates ist wahrscheinlich hier überall sexuelle Belästigung, da denkt sich ja Leute, wo ist euer Hashtag, Kinder, ihr könnt mir nichts. Ihr könnt mir nichts. Bill Gates Gates, Gates, Gates. Gate Gates. Ja, aber MeToo nervt auch schon, der Name nervt schon. Tolle Bewegung, aber leider ist es Hashtag MeToo, wo man auch denkt, das ist doch auch Quatsch. Me as well könnte man ja auch machen. Ja, also man kann sich ja ein bisschen gebildeter ausdrücken. Ja, auch auf Französisch. Wenn man schon bei diesem ganzen Gessourien... Moi aussi.
Wie läuft es eigentlich beim Französischlernen?
Nicht gut.
Nee?
Nee, nicht gut.
Ich kriege ständig Mails, dass ich die Sachen von anderen Leuten korrigieren soll.
Wo ich mir denke, ich bin selber der größte Depp und habe keine Ahnung von gar nichts und soll Leute korrigieren.
Weil die App ja darauf basiert, dass man selber Sachen schreibt, die andere korrigieren.
Aber die brauchen natürlich, damit das System funktioniert, auch Leute, die was korrigieren. Und seitdem funktioniert es nicht mehr. Aber es ist nicht diese App, es ist nicht Bubble, oder? Nee, es ist nicht Bubble. Bei Bubble, da habe ich jetzt mit einem Kollegen gesprochen, der so nebenbei am Handy die ganze Zeit am Bubble, am Rum-Bubbeln war, und dann hat tatsächlich seine Freundin, dachte er spielt die ganze Zeit irgendwie Candy Crush oder so einen Scheiß und hat die ganze Zeit auch gesagt, Alter, jetzt geh mal von deinem Handy weg. Und dann irgendwann waren die dann einfach im Frankreich Urlaub und er kam in den Laden und hat fließend Französisch gesprochen und sie dachte, was war mit dir denn los, wusste nicht, was er da die ganze Zeit macht und offensichtlich hat Bubble da geholfen. Tatsächlich, es gibt auch noch eine andere App, Duolingo heißt die und die ist ja super link, weil was die macht, die macht sozialen Druck. Und Soziale gibt, glaube ich, keine Kraft, die stärker ist als Soziale. Was? Was ist das? Vor unserem Fernseher so ganz langsam so ein Reisebus entlang geschoben. Wirklich? Mit sehr vielen Leuten, die reingucken? Ich sehe es leider. Nee, gar nicht, gar nicht. Der wird ja nur gewaschen. Das ist wieder für einen Raum, in dem wir heute sitzen. Aber ganz kurz, Duolingo, und zwar, was da ist, du kannst dich vernetzen mit deinen Freunden, die das auch machen, und dann siehst du, und dann kann man so Streaks machen, also wie viele Tage in Folge man seine Lektionen macht. Genau. Und du siehst, wie lang der Streak von den anderen Leuten ist. Das heißt, ah, Nina ist gerade auf dem Streak von 21 und ich bin auf 20, das heißt, wenn ich heute nicht lerne, überholt mich Nina.
Fucking Nina.
So, das heißt, du mit dranbleiben.
Streber Nina.
Jetzt denkt man sich, ja, ist ja ganz nett irgendwie, kann man Leute motivieren, irgendwie dann dran zu bleiben, aber pass auf, wenn du einen Tag mal nicht lernst, weißt du, was du dann machen kannst?
Dann kannst du denen Geld zahlen, dass dein Streak nicht abbricht.
Das ist genial.
Wie, also, ich hab das nur aus zweiter Quelle, aber ich denke mir, wie brillant ist das denn, und vor allem wie link, weil ihr meintet dann so, ja, ich kenn jemanden, der hat irgendwie einen Streak von 400 Tagen oder sowas, seit Jahren, ich weiß doch nicht, warum die aus dem Anfängerkurs nicht rauskommen. Aber das ist wie in der Schule, die Reichen schummeln sich durch. Ja, und vor allem, also du kaufst dir einfach Prestige, du kaufst dir einfach, dass deine Freunde denken, oh wow, der ist bei Spanisch schon in Lektion Tres und ich bin noch in Uno. Also das ist ja brillant. Ich finde, du brauchst nicht cheaten. Das klappt schon sehr gut offensichtlich. Ja, ich weiß. Danke. Wir haben eine tolle Nachricht bekommen zu dem Thema von Franziska. Hallo ihr beiden, letzte Woche habt ihr über die wahnsinnig motivierenden und positiven Beispielsätze einer französischen Lern-App gesprochen. Ich bin angehender französische Lehrerin und schaue mir gelegentlich auch ein paar Lern-Apps an. Anbei das Best-of
der motivierenden Beispielsätze.
Und da hat sie uns zwei Screenshots aus dieser App gesendet.
Und zwar der erste Satz ist
Person ne plus eviter
l'am, ich kann nicht. Niemand kann dem
Tod entgehen, war der
Beispielsatz.
Und das zweite Beispiel,
übersetzt sie diesen Satz,
elle ira, on fair, sie wird in die Hölle kommen. Außerdem merken wir die religiöse Konnotation dabei, oder? Sie wird in die, und jetzt declinieren wir alle, sie wird in die Hölle kommen. Du wirst in die Hölle kommen, wir werden in die Hölle kommen. Wir alle werden in die Hölle kommen. Du wirst in die Hölle gekommen worden sein. Niemand wird nicht in die Hölle kommen.
Aber das Nichtlehr wird auch erst nächste Woche.
Aber das ist so, das ist schon echt hart.
Aber vor allem, es sind manchmal auch so perfide Sachen.
Ich hatte ja den Satz, niemand ist zu meiner Geburtstagsfeier gekommen.
Ich denke, das ist unnötig hart einfach.
Mein Hölle, das ist ja noch geckig irgendwo.
Vielleicht auch Französisch zu lernen.
Und über die mir eine Freundin.
Ja, genau. Nimm mal ab.
Ich war seit acht Tagen nicht draußen.
Weil ich nur Französisch lerne.
Wow. Wir haben eine Französischlehrerin als Hörerin.
Das ist ja super.
Die kann mir Französisch beibringen.
Ach, letzte Woche dieser Uni-Leipzig-Typ.
Sorry.
Ich habe langsam wirklich Angst,
dass unsere Hörer uns meilenweit voraus sind. Ja, vor allem, ich habe das Gefühl, dass mittlerweile wir als Podcaster zu dienen, dass sich mittelkluge Leute richtig klug fühlen können. Man hört uns sozusagen als, die sind noch dümmer als ich, weil ich meine, sind wir mal ehrlich, Akademiker haben heute nicht mehr so den Prestige, wie es früher mal war. Heute sagst du, oh, ich habe einen Abschluss in Kulturwissenschaften, die Leute sagen, eher, wirst du für ein Trottel, damit kann man nichts machen. Das heißt, diese Leute haben kein soziales Prestige mehr. Dieses alte Versprechen von, studier dein Leben lang und du wirst einen hohen sozialen Status bekommen, gibt es nicht mehr. The German Dream. The German Dream ist weg. Das ist tot. Das heißt, was machen diese Leute? Ihr ganzes Wissen, ihr völlig unnützes Wissen, das auf dem Finanzmarkt keinen Wert hat, nehmen sie jetzt und wenden es auf uns an, die wir keine Ahnung haben, um sich gut zu fühlen. Ich glaube, wir sind so was wie mittlerweile wie Schwierertochter gesucht oder Frauentausch, was man früher geguckt hat, um sich besser zu fühlen. Ja, wir sind wie so ein Boxsack, den man einfach drauf schlagen kann, weil man weiß, wir wehren uns, wir können es nicht wehren. Dumm genug, dass sie die ganze Sache ihre Brabeleien aufnehmen. Und hier ist Wissen. Wir haben eine tolle, letzte Woche, heute ist die Community-Folge, wir lesen mal ein paar Sachen vor. Und zwar haben wir letzte Woche über Tattoos gesprochen, und dass es auch passieren kann, dass sich Rechtschreibfehler einschleichen. Hurros never die. Genau, da kam erstens ein Tipp von einem Nutzer, dass man daraus Churros never die machen kann. Sehr gut, ja, bei dem H-U kann man noch ein C davor setzen. Was heißt denn Churros? Churros ist dieses spanische Dessert. Wurst. Das ist ein spanisches Dessert. Ach so. Dieses kleinen, dieses Spritzgebäck, so frittiertes Spritzgebäckartiges Gedöns. Mega lecker, du wirst instant dicker. Aber diese Churritos ist diese Salami, ne? Ja, Chorithos ist diese rote Salami. Die sind zu scharf. Die ist, glaube ich, zu scharf, Laurentin. Pack die mal wieder weg. Wie kriegt man die so rot? Ist nicht das Fleisch so rot? Ich glaube, Farbstoff. Aber das ganze Tier muss ja dann, das ist ja das Fleisch. Ey, die geben dem Tier Farbstoff. Nein. Stefan, wie kommt es dann in die Muskeln? Ich hatte mal so eine Chorizo-Phase. Ich erinnere mich sehr gut daran, Stefan. Ich erinnere mich sehr gut daran. Die Fähnchen waren zu viel. Dann habe ich die Brötchen belegt mit Chorizo. Und dann kennt man das manchmal, wenn man das nicht gut belegt. Und dann hat man Chorizo hängen irgendwo im Mund und dann ist das Brötchen leer, weil man mit einem Bissen aus Versehen das ganze Chorizo-Gedöns weggegessen hat und dann alles aneinander hängt. Und dann sieht man, das Brötchen ist rot, weil es sind Interlässe, das sind roten Farbstoff, das kann nicht gut sein. Ist das der Schweiß? Ist das der Chorizo-Schweiß? Blut. Ich finde die aber ganz gut, weil die haben eine große Mundgröße. Und das ist ja eigentlich, Brotbelag ist ja immer kritisch, gerade auf Pizzen hat man ja oft Salamischeiben, die grösser sind als ein Biss, was schrecklich ist, weil du willst nicht direkt reinbeißen, weil dann gequillt es an der Seite raus oder so, aber du schlingst es auch nicht die ganze Salamiseite rein. Deswegen, ich frag mich seit Jahren, warum ist, und das einzige, wie man das umgeben kann, ist mit der Diabola, ist mit den scharfen Salamis, die aus irgendeinem Grund kleiner sind. Und obwohl ich scharfe nicht so gern mag, würde ich mir das viel lieber holen, weil es einfach so eine Mundgröße hat. Warum ist noch niemand auf die jene gekommen, die normale Salamipizza mit Salamischeiben zu belegen, die einfach mundgross sind, die nicht so riesig sind. Ja, und das so zu belegen, dass man, wenn man die Pizza schneidet, nicht durch eine Salami schneiden muss. Ja ist aber Frechheit so. Die kalkulieren das mathematisch genauso. Das wäre mal eine lebensreiche Mathematikaufnahme. Wie muss man die Salami legen, damit man mit Strichen die wenigsten Salamis durchschneiden muss? Ja, das wäre gut. Das macht niemand. Niemand. Ja, vor allem das ist ja dann auch immer so, also da kann man ja wirklich eine Matheaufgabe machen, weil die müssen dann auch an den Orten liegen, dass sie nicht grösser sind als das Pizzaachtel an der Stelle.
Genau, das Pizzaachtel muss, also sagen wir mal, die Mitte des Pizzaachtels, damit meine ich die Ankertete des Pizzaachtels, die Mitte davon, darf nicht kleiner als Salamidurchmesser sein. Genau, dafür brauchst du aber relativ kleine Salamen. Du hast ja in der Mittelmitte, ist ja nicht die Mitte der Fläche. Oh, wenn man Pizza schneidet, das kann für mich den Genuss der Pizza ruinieren, wenn der erste Schnitt nicht sitzt. Was denn zum Thema Pizzaschere? Als ich die Pizzaschere gesehen habe, dachte ich mir, okay, jetzt ist Zeit für Revolutionen, weil seit jeher galt der Pizzaroller als absolut ungeschlagenes Werkzeug zur Pizzaküche. Aber eigentlich hat er ja immer schon Fehler. Eigentlich war der Pizzaroller immer schon Fehler. Ich meine, in dem Karton perfekt, weil du einen weichen Untergrund hast. Auf dem Teller schlecht. Quietscht, kreischt, du hast nicht die richtige Höhe. Deswegen eigentlich ist die Schere, du hast nur Druck von oben. Dadurch drückst du auch teilweise irgendwie den Pilz von der Pizza oder die Salami auseinander. Eigentlich ist die Schere viel besser. Und beim Teich sagt, okay, ich werde geschnitten. Salami sagt, nope, auf keinen Fall. Ihr quetscht mich breit. Ja, ihr quetscht mich in die Ritze zwischen dem Teig aus dem Boden. Genau, aber ich werde noch nicht geschnitten. Nope. Und der Käse sagt, okay, ich bleibe gleich ganz, ich haue ab, Freunde. Ich bleibe am Roller hängen. Ich ziehe dich einmal klar ins Wohnzimmer. Ich bleibe am Roller hängen und bin unbeeindruckt von der Schnittschärfe. Ja. Der klebt sich an die Seite dran. Deswegen, eigentlich ist Pizzaschere eine geile Idee, weil du es von beiden Seiten hast, gleichmäßig schnipp, schnipp, schnipp, aber hat sich nicht durchgesetzt. Hat sich nicht durchgesetzt, weil du dir anheben musst. Ja. Gut, Gutenberg, Buchdruck, ich sag Pizzadruck. Du musst einfach nur für verschiedene Grössen einer Pizza das optimale Schneidewerkzeug haben. Also so, dass du wie so eine grosse Bleiplatte mit dafür vorgesehenen Schneiden... Schwer zu waschen. Schwer zu waschen. So Messern nach oben. Nee, nee, nee, schwer zu waschen. Die Scharniere sind immer schlecht, Gelenke sind immer schlecht zu waschen. Ja, jetzt aber nimm doch locker die Hälfte meiner Küche ein, dieses Gerät ein bisschen juicer ist fantastisch wir bekommen eine nachricht sorry ich will ganz kurz drauf bleiben nein was
willst du hast du den schon benutzt ja was hast du damit gejuiced himbeeren brombeeren er Himbeeren, Brombeeren, Erdbeeren, Birne, Apfel, Banane, oh, Banane war nicht gut. Aber was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem Smoothie-Maker und einem Juicer? Ich glaube, Smoothie-Maker ist im Kern Mixer. Schauen wir der Wahrheit mal gnadenlos ins Gesicht. Ja, ich glaube Smoothies, da brauchst du keine Gerätschaft für, weil du ja nicht den Saft extrahierst, sondern da kannst du ja recht klein mixen. Oder nicht? Weiß ich nicht. Stefan, du hast 180 Euro dafür auszugeben, du musst es wissen. Die Mails laufen schon wieder Sturm. So, Lea schreibt eine Mitschülerin, natürlich gerade frische 18 Jahre alt geworden, rannte Schnurstracks zum Dätowierer. Ich finde gut, Wörter wie Schnurstracks. Ja, Schnurstracks ist wirklich... Rubbel die Katz, sowas. Sie schaut auf ihr Handgelenk, auf die Uhr in drei, zwei, eins und raus zur Tür und ab zum Tätowierer. Zum Tätowierer ihres Vertrauens. Okay. Um sich ihren langersehnten und jedem mitgeteilten, bestimmt jeder Person mitgeteileilten Traum der Körperkunst zu erfüllen.
Ein Tattoo, das ihren gesamten oberen Rücken ausfüllen sollte, mit dem Tammlerspruch Nummer eins aus dem Jahr 2012, Who are you when no one is watching? Ich weiß schon, wie es ausgeht, das ist wirklich lustig. Who are you when nobody can see your clever tattoo? Leider hatte der Tätowierer wohl keinen Sinn für die Tiefe dieser Botschaft, weshalb es unglücklicherweise dazu kam, dass er einen entscheidenden Teil der Phrase vergass. Who are you when one is watching? Who are you when one is watching? Ah, sehr schön. Who are you when one is watching? Man kann es auch so betonen vielleicht. Wie bist du, wenn jemand zuschaut? Ja. Aber mir gefällt, dass es nach wie vor diese scheinbare Tiefe hat, dieser Ausspruch. Aber strange ist, wie bist du, wenn jemand zuschaut? Somebody is always watching. Ich meine, es tut mir leid, vielleicht ist das jetzt einfach eine sehr herablassende, objektifizierende Sicht auf den weiblichen Körper. Da mache ich mich auch absolut schuldig. Und vielleicht bin ich auch einfach versaut, was das angeht. Aber ich finde, es ist zum Beispiel so, wenn du deinem Kind Namen gibst, musst du immer gucken, kann man da irgendeinen dummen Spitznamen draus machen. Das ist einfach deine Pflicht als Eltern. Nicht, weil du schlecht bist, sondern weil die Welt schlecht ist. Deswegen musst du das vorbeugen. Genau wie du deine App benennst, musst du gucken, kann man da nicht irgendwie Penis draus machen. Nicht weil du schlecht bist, sondern weil die Welt schlecht ist und du eine Verantwortung hast, dein Produkt zu beschützen. Was hast du gegen Enes? Projekt Enes? Nein. Hä? Stefan, Projekt Enes ist ein Standort. Lass es, es funktioniert nicht. Die Leute werden da mit dem Filzstift was draufschreiben. Und deswegen denke ich mir, erst mal Tattoos, die man selber nicht sieht, finde ich schwierig. Und zweitens, ich finde, man muss ja auch daran denken, wie das ist zum Beispiel bei verschiedenen sexuellen Stellungen, wo der Rücken der Frau dann plötzlich in den Fokus des Mannes gerückt wird. und man sich dann ich sehe was wenn man angenommen man ist. Wenn man, angenommen, man ist in der Position Doggy-Style. Richtig. So, und dann hat man, dann lächelt einen an, who are you when nobody's watching? Ja, oder who are you when one is watching? Du denkst mir, who's watching? Oder ich habe auch... Man dreht sich so leise um. Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich nur mein Ding ist und ob das total respektlos ist, mag sein. Aber ich habe auch mal von jemandem gehört, die gesagt hat, ja, keine Ahnung, so mein, ich glaube, mein Bruder ist bei der Geburt gestorben oder sowas. Und deswegen habe ich mir ein Bild von irgendwie so Rest in Peace oder so direkt auf meinen Rücken tätowieren lassen, mit einem Gesicht von dem Säugling mit den Jahreszeilen, wo ich mir denke, die arme Sau, die vielleicht mit dir irgendwann schlafen wird und dann einfach in den sonst so schönen 24 Sekunden, die man aktiv ist, einfach in das tote Gesicht eines ungeborenen Bruders schaut.
Ich meine, es ist natürlich nicht die Verantwortung einer Frau, sich möglichst gut für den...
Ja, red dich da ruhig raus.
Ja, ich meine nur, ich finde, man sollte darauf aufachten.
Das ist ein lustiges Bild.
Am Montag in der Schule wusste bereits jeder Bescheid und wollte einen Blick auf das Kunstwerk erhaschen. Glück hatten die, die im selben Sportkurs waren. Oh Gott. Die Frage, wie man das Ganze noch retten, eventuell ein Sternchen mit No unten rechts über dem Po oder Sinn verleihen konnte. Ja, viel Spaß. Viel Spaß, und dann siehst du das Tattoo losgetrennt von allen anderen. No. Einfach nur das Wort No.
Dann finde ich auch nicht schlecht die Idee,
ein Tattoo-Model zu werden.
Ja, so ein Vorher, von so einer Laser-Entfernung. Das ist eh egal.
Aber gerade mit einem schlechten Tattoo kannst du doch nicht
zum Tattoo-Model werden.
Ich glaube, für so Beispielhefte
und so, dass du jetzt einfach
auf dir rummalen kannst.
Ach so, jetzt machst du einfach Scheiß drauf. Wenn dein Körper ein Papier wäre, würde es zusammenknüllen und wegschmeißen. Ich glaube, ja, das stimmt schon, ja. Ja, doch, um eure Frage zu antworten, bezahlt hat sie die Misere trotzdem, obwohl ihre Freunde sie gedrängt haben, noch einmal zum Studio zurückzugehen und sich das Geld wiedergeben zu lassen. Ihre Art der Rettung war übrigens ein Wolf, der einen Mond anheult. Der sie gebissen hat, also wegen einer riesigen Narbe am Rücken. Die Rettung war übrigens ein Wolf, der einen Mond anheult. Ich dachte schon, der sie gebissen hat, also wegen der riesigen Narbe am Rücken. Ihre Rettung war der Suizid. Gerüchten zufolge, beim selben Tätowierer, aber angerufen. Gott! Warum auch immer. Kein Golf! Ein Wolf! Sie dachte, du bist VW-Fan. Ein Golf! Aber Moment mal. Ein Golf Golf, der James Bond anheult. Aber das heißt, sie hat einen Wolf, der in den Text reinragt oder was. Das sieht ja total merkwürdig aus. Ich glaube, das ist Oh von No. Who are you when Mond is watching? Was? Das wird immer verwirrender. Es wird so eine Art neuen Live-Rätsel. Oh Mann. Der Hot-Button schlägt. Was meint sie mit diesem Rätsel? Aber das ist also, ich verstehe, also fast nichts an der Geschichte verstehe ich. Fast nichts. Ich habe auch viele Fragen. Also wirklich, sich direkt ein Tattoo machen wollen, dann an einer Position, an der man es selbst nicht sieht und dann noch mit so einem Spruch, also ich meine, ich habe nichts gegen solche Sprüche, ist ja völlig in Ordnung, aber dann wirklich mit so einem Drängen, ich kann verstehen, wenn wirklich irgendwas Persönliches passiert oder sowas, oder wenn man jetzt, wenn man sagt, sie wäre gerade total verliebt in ihren Freund und geht davon aus, sie sich niemals trennen und sie will unbedingt den Namen ihres Freundes tätowiert haben, okay, verstehe ich, ist irgendwie irrational, kann man mal machen impulsiv, Aber so ein Spruch, Who are you when no one is watching, das ist der Spruch? Ich meine, was ist denn mit allen Sprüchen geworden? Ja, vor allem an die Leute, die hinter ihr sind, aber auch nicht immer. Also, vor allem ein Tattoo sagt das Gegenteil von Who are you when no one is watching? Ja. Weil du willst ja die Leute angucken und du hast ein Tattoo nur, weil sie dich angucken können. Aber macht sie es auf dem Rücken, um zu symbolisieren, ich kann dich gerade nicht sehen, weil du meinen Rücken siehst? Und I am who I am when no one is watching? Ja, aber da müsste sie ja allen die ganze Zeit den Rücken zudrehen. Oder weil das Tattoo niemand sieht. Im Sinne von, ich mache mir das Tattoo auch, wenn niemand es sieht. Im Sinne von, ich mach es mir eben nicht für andere, sondern für mich an der Stelle, wo es niemand sieht. Ja, ich glaube, es ist falsch, da es einen tieferen Sinn zu suchen. Ich glaube, wer schnurstrackt mit 18 Jahren. Schnurstrackt und sagt, entweder Around the World, Around the World, oder Who are you when no one is watching? Eins von beiden. Wir haben Blue, Dabbedee,, Double Die, Double Die, Sie haben ein Double Die vergessen. Da ist kein Double, es heißt nicht Double Die, Double Die. Double Die, Double Die, Double Die, Double Die, Mega Song. Ist der beste Song, der jemals aufgenommen wurde, muss man sagen. Manche Wünsche, wir haben so eine Radiosender, die manchmal einfach Lieder ansagen können. Du kannst dir ein Lied ansagen. Ja, klar. Hör ich Lied ansagen? Ja, klar. Solange es nicht Rowan Keating mit Life is a Rollercoaster ist, kannst du alles dir wünschen. Ich wünsche mir von Smash Mouth den Hit. Ja, wir brauchen jetzt schon langsam die Antwort. Wahrscheinlich Allstar. wahrscheinlich mein Den Hit ...
Ja, wir bräuchten jetzt schon langsam die Antwort.
Wahrscheinlich All-Star. Wahrscheinlich meinst du All-Star.
Ähm ... When the morning comes.
Then the morning comes, die hören jetzt ...
Boah, ich dachte, die haben nur diesen einen Song.
Ach so stimmt, Smash Mouth. Die haben ja Walking on the Sun.
Ja, tatsächlich im Walking on the Sun.
Didi-didit-didit.
Hier mehr Hits? Didi-didit-didit. Da hab ich sehr viel gehört, als ich fünfzehn war. Sende, Monica? Leute, hallo, hallo, Gema, Gema, Gema, Gema, Gema, Gema, Gema, Gema, Gema. Ich tatsächlich hab ich gelesen ... Du machst es nicht legal, wenn du jetzt eine Gema sagst. Doch, ich hab tatsächlich gelesen, es ist legal, wenn du während der Song läuft Gema, Gema, Gema sagst, weil dann bist du dir klar, dass du ein Verbrechen machst. Warum dieser Tanz, der Gema-Tanz, den du da auch... Das muss sein. Okay. Habe ich nicht mehr ausgedacht, steht im Gesetz. Ich habe jetzt meine Gema-Abrechnung bekommen. 1,42 tatsächlich. Größer als... 1,42 Euro. 1,42 Euro. Das war mein Ertrag. Ja, hallo, Cash, Cash. Ja, Cash, Cash. Sehr gut. Eine gemischte Tüte. Ich habe heute eine Strafzeit bekommen. Also erst mal, ich bin dumm. Exibitismus. Jeder, der eine Strafzeit bekommen, ist dumm. Und so lag ein Brief bei mir im Briefkasten. Und dann manchmal, also ich bin ja neugieriger Typ. Und dann gibt es ja diese Fensterbriefumschläge, wo man schon so ein bisschen was vom Brief lugen kann. So ein bisschen. Und ich gucke dann da rein und dann stand vom Polizeipräsidenten der Stadt Berlin. Ja, Moment, ganz kurz. Oh. Und ich denke mir, wenn man keinen Brief bekommen will vom Polizeipräsidenten der Stadt Berlin. Warum muss der denn direkt schreiben? Wo ich mir dachte, hey, Gustav, relax. Holy shit. Okay, ich bin nicht in Berlin. Aber er macht auf Ernst. Er macht auf Ernst so. Und es war, ich weiß auch nicht genau, was es war, es war irgendwie Übertretung der Linie. Welche Linie? Welche Linie? Habe ich nicht gelesen, aber anscheinend habe ich das nicht gelesen. Ich glaube, damit ist die rote Ampel gemeint, aber die haben das da ganz komisch formuliert. Ja, oder Humorlinie? Ich weiss auch nicht, des guten Geschmacks, keine Ahnung. Ja, die Linie des guten Geschmacks. Und vor allem ich glaube, ich hatte nicht dabei, und vor allem stand dann da Zeuge, Zeuge, Herr und dann irgendein Nachname. Und ich dachte mir, was? Und vor allem, war das ein Strafzettel? Oh, das kann ich nicht. Jemand hat gesnitscht. Jemand hat gesnitscht, das war ein Strafzettel. Und da dachte ich mir, okay, jetzt kommt richtig was auf mich zu. Jemand hat die Polizei gerufen, jemand hat gesehen, dass ich irgendwas gemacht habe. Stand da ein Name? Da stand ein Name tatsächlich.
Stand drauf, welches ist das? Ja, da stand ein Name drauf. Und wenn man
den etwas anders schreibt,
dann kommt der mir bekannt vor. Möchte ich nicht
darauf eingehen, machen wir nach der Aufnahme.
Aber ich dachte mir, weil, keine Ahnung, so ein normales
Verkehrsvergehen ist ja Blitzer oder sowas, der völlig
automatisiert wahrscheinlich so.
Zäuge, Doppelpunkt, Blitzer,
Nummer, so und so. Blitzi, Mr. Blitz. Und dann dachte ich mir, wenn da ein Zeuge steht, heißt es ja, jemand hat mich gesehen und hat dann mein Kennzeichen aufgeschrieben, dann die Polizei gerufen, dann muss es ja wirklich ein krasses Delikt sein, weil kein Mensch macht im Straßenverkehr ausser du fährst jetzt den Fahrradfahrer um oder so, dann würde man die Polizei rufen. Dann würde man auch nicht schreiben, du hast eine Linie übertreten.
Ich würde sagen, Mord ist
Linie übertreten. Es ist auch eine Linie übertreten, ja.
Du hast gewisse Grenzen überschritten.
Ich glaube, im neuen Strafgesetzbuch
wird jeder Strafbestand ersetzt durch
Wir haben eine Linie übertreten. Sie haben eine Linie übertreten?
Linien übertreten. Das ging zu weit.
Paragraph 864
Linie übertreten. Welche Linie? Es war letzten Endes 10 Euro. Und bei 10 Euro Aber es ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das? Der will mich verarschen. Ich weiß nicht, was da los ist. Aber tatsächlich, ich habe es nicht verstanden. Vielleicht ist der Zeuge auch ein Polizist gewesen. Und der dann automatisch auch Zeuge ist. Aber stand der Herr Gronkowski oder? Ja, da stand sowas in der Richtung, ja. Aber stand nicht Herr Polizist Gronkowski. Keine Ahnung. Oder der Polizeipräsident hat dich gesehen. Nee, ich kenne auch Gustav, ich kenne Gusti. Aber wie findet man raus, ob die Person, man muss da nicht dabei, das ist ja für mich wichtig, in so einem juristischen Rahmen, ob diese Person jetzt einfach ein Mitbürger ist oder ein Polizist, weil das würde mich ja schon ändern, ob das wirklich jemand gesnitscht hat. Weil wenn der mich snitscht, snitsche ich zurück, snitsches geht snitsches, dann mache ich ernst. Der hat für mich eine Linie übertreten. Oh, das darf man nicht immer so sagen. Aber als ich das mal gemacht habe, als ich eine Linie übertreten habe, das habe ich mir mal erzählt, die Geschichte, wo ich dann aus Versehen geflohen bin, weil ich Kopfhörer im Ohr. Aus Versehen geflohen, ich bin den Hügel runtergerollt, ich wollte gar nicht fliehen. Das habe ich mir mal erzählt. Da bin ich doch dann schnellen Schrittes. Ja, genau, wo du über die rotte Ampel bist. Genau, da hatte ich Kopfhörer im Ohr und war aber dann schon zu Hause und bin dann halt sehr schnell gegangen, wie ich immer gehe, habe nicht gesehen, dass hinter mir ein Verfolgungswerk ausgebrochen ist, mit Blaulicht und so, und Polizisten, die hinter mir hergerannt sind. Und dann war ich schon zu Hause, bin in meine Haustür eingebaut, die Tür fällt ins Schloss und dann wirft sich so ein Polizist in die Tür rein und sagt so, hätte ich so zu mir sein können. Können wir Foto machen. Und dann tatsächlich wollten die dann einfach mir sagen, dass ich eine Rote Ampel, eine Linie übertreten habe. Und dann haben die dann, dann dachte ich mir auch, das ist auch nicht, also können die jetzt einfach so machen. Können die jetzt auch einfach in meine Wohnung rein? Und dann habe ich denen 10 Euro in den Bar gegeben und dachte mir, das ist ja... Er hat sich einen schönen Eis gekauft, einen Piccolo-Becher. Was man aus so Stripper-Filmen kennt. Du hast der Polizistin nicht den Schein in den Kragen geschoben. Ins Dekolleté, wie ich gesehen habe. Stefan, wie ich es aus Filmen kenne. Und dann dachte ich mir, kann ich jetzt auch sagen, man will nicht derjenige sein, der sagt, ich kenne meine Rechte, Sie können mir gar nicht in Bar das abverlangen. Das will man ja auch nicht sein. Man will ja irgendwie auch sagen, okay, Sie haben Recht, ich habe eine Linie übertreten, ich habe das Kind umgebracht, bitteschön, hier sind die zehn Euro. Aber irgendwie denkt man auch, manchmal sollte man seine Rechte doch kennen. Und ich glaube, die können nicht von dir direkt das verlangen. Und du könntest eine Aussage von einem Zeugen verlangen. Du musst sie bezahlen. Sind Verkehrspolizisten die dummen Polizisten? Warum? Wollen die Verkehrspolizisten sein oder müssen die Verkehrspolizisten sein? Weil niemand, der zur Polizei geht, sagt, ich will Verkehrspolizist werden. Mir wäre das ja auch unangenehm. Ich habe kein Problem, mit Verbrechern hinterher zu rennen und einen Drogenring auszuheben, aber jetzt zu sagen, ja passend auf, sie fahren ohne Helm, das macht
jetzt 15 Euro, das ist ja
schrecklich. Oder ich
weiß nicht, ist das so, wird man da einfach viel eingeteilt?
Du gehst jetzt zur GSG 9,
du machst hier jetzt irgendwie
GSG 7, je nachdem, und du machst
jetzt Fahrerpatrouille? GSG 1?
Oh, nein.
Tatsächlich finde ich es noch viel spannender
und das ist total weird. Ich bin jeden Morgen, wenn ich mit dem Auto komme, ich fahre oft mit der Bahn, aber so einmal im Monat fahre ich mit dem Auto zur Arbeit, weil ich meistens dann zu spät bin.
Und immer komme ich an diese Einstelle vorbei, wo ein Polizeiauto steht.
Und da dachte ich mir, irgendwer ist hier unter Personenschutz.
Und da habe ich mir herausgefunden, warum die da stehen, weil da eine Synagoge ist, eine kleine, die fällt nicht auf und deswegen wusste ich, wie es eine Synagoge ist.
Aber das ist, glaube ich, in allen deutschen Synagogen werden die ganze Zeit von Polizisten bewacht. Und dann kommt da morgens ein Streifenwagen an, so ein Bulli, hält er dann an und dann sitzt da den ganzen Tag ein Polizist drin, der die Synagoge anguckt und fährt abends nach Hause. Was ist das denn für ein Beruf? Das sind ja Polizisten. Das ist ja nicht so, dass da irgendwie ein Azubi hingesetzt wird oder Personenschützer. Nein, das sind Polizisten. Ja, bist du dir sicher, dass da überhaupt ein Polizist drinsitzt? Weil was ich machen würde, ich würde da einfach ein Fake-Auto hinstellen den ganzen Tag, während der Polizist andere Sachen macht. Weil wenn da jetzt irgendwie Nazis kommen und da irgendwie Hakenkreuz in den Gummelschmieren wollen, da steht direkt ein Polizei-Auto davor, dann reicht das ja schon, bis es in einem Polizeiauto steht. Oder nicht? Das reicht ja auch, wenn die Bulli da hinstellen, wo sie mit Edding Pozilei draufschreiben. Das reicht ja dann auch oder was. Ich weiß nicht. Was willst du jetzt damit sagen? Ich weiß nicht. Ist auch geil, dass die Polizei, auf dem Auto vorne ist es ja falsch rumgeschrieben. Oh ja, in Spiegelschrift. Wie genial ist das denn? Wenn du in Wenn du in den Rückspiegel schaust, liest du Polizei. Kann man nicht einfach beim Auto das wieder entspiegeln, dass man durch zwei Spiegel schaut? Das check ich überhaupt nicht. Spiegel habe ich noch nie verstanden. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert. Wie funktioniert Spiegel? Das geht zum Beispiel mit meinem Kopf nicht rein. Diese Frage habe ich auch schon mal gestellt, aber ich habe keine Antwort bekommen. Und wir wollen auch keine Antwort. Bitte schreibt weniger Mails. Doch, darauf will ich meine Antwort. Nein, wir ersticken in Mails. Ja, ihr Nobelpreisträger da draußen, die in unserem Podcast offensichtlich hören. Wieso ist es so, dass wenn ich in den Spiegel schaue und dann... Pass auf, pass auf. Ich kriege so viele nervige Mails. Nee, aber ganz kurz, das ist wirklich eine entspannte Frage. Ich bin kurzsichtig. Ich sehe das in der Ferne. In der Ferne sehe ich Dinge nicht. Nah sehe ich die sehr scharf. So, deswegen brauche ich eine Brille. Wenn ich jetzt ohne Brille in den Rückspiegel schaue, sehe ich den Rückspiegel ja scharf. Warum ist trotzdem alles, was ich im Rückspiegel sehe, unscharf? Weil das, was ich sehe, ist ja sehr nah, ist ja 20 cm von mir entfernt. Aber weißt du, das Auto, was ich im Rückspiegel, ist ja trotzdem unscharf. Warum?
Das wird doch reflektiert.
Wenn du einen Film auf der Leinwand schaust, siehst du alles scharf.
Ja, wenn die Leinwand nah dran ist, ja.
Wenn ich nicht in der letzten Reihe setze.
Aber verstehst du, was ich meine?
Die Distanz, ich meine, das Licht kommt ja da rein,
in den Spiegel alles.
Aber du kannst doch innerhalb des Spiegels auch auf verschiedene Distanzebenen scharf stellen, oder nicht? Ja, aber warum? Warum? Das ist doch 2D. Das Spiegel ist doch 2D. Ich weiß die Lösung, Leute. Ich weiß die Lösung. Weil das Licht, das wird ja gebrochen quasi. Und die Lichtwellen sind ja dann keine anderen. Aber es ist doch trotzdem ein bisschen paradox. Oder nicht? Das ist verrückt. Sagen wir auch Podcast-Ufo-T-Shirts rausbringen, wo es gespiegelt ist für Autofahrer? Ja, finde ich gut. Oder wo es hinten drauf ist. Wo es hinten drauf ist und gespiegelt. Who are you when nobody is watching? Wer bist du, wenn niemand guckt? Und das in Spiegelschrift. Und das interessiert mich. Das ist doch ein guter Gag, in das in Spiegelschrift, weil dann ist es nur für Leute zu lesen, die nicht... Ach, das ist schwierig. Nee, in dem Shirt, wenn man das Shirt auf links dreht, steht da drin, who are you when nobody is watching? Oder innen Shirt, innen drin. Ja, ja, ja, sag ja, innen drin. Ach so, auf links, verstehe. Oder auf rechts, halt die andere Seite halt. Je nach links, wenn du links händest, dann bist du auf rechts. Warum sagt man nach links drehen, warum nicht nach aussen ja, innen drin. Wenn du auf links drehst oder auf rechts, halt die andere Seite halt.
Wenn du Linkshänder bist, auf rechts.
Warum sagt man auf links drehen, nach aussen oder nach innen?
Warum muss man da die falsche Bezeichnung von Richtungen einbringen?
Ich weiss es nicht, Florentin.
Ich weiss es doch nicht!
Aber wer bist du, wenn jemand auf den Kinn guckt?
Das weiss ich ja eben nicht.
Woher soll ich das? Ich weiss es nicht.
Jetzt frage ich dich hier. Ich frage dich.
Who are you when nobody's watching?
Florentin Will.
Man benimmt sich schon ein bisschen anders.
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist auch nicht die großartige Erkenntnis.
Ich habe mich mal abends alleine betrunken
und habe dann getanzt
in meiner Wohnung. Wirklich? Zu welcher Musik?
Nein, aber angenommen, du bist allein
in deiner Wohnung und du hörst ein gutes Lied.
Und aus irgendeinem Grund, weil du gerade drauf bist, würdest du tanzen.
Würdest du so tanzen, wie du im Club tanzen würdest? Und ich behaupte nein.
Wenn du alleine tanzt, tanzt du anders.
Kommt drauf an. Ich glaube, es gibt schon Leute, die auch wirklich so tanzen, wie sie zu Hause tanzen würden.
Mit steigendem Alkohol, der wird, glaube ich, wird es immer wahrscheinlicher.
Aber es stimmt schon, es ist schwierig.
Ich war mal für so einen 1Live-Beitrag, war ich mal irgendwann in dieser einen Woche, wo ich da gearbeitet habe und danach nie wieder hingegangen bin.
Da war ich in so einem Bootshaus, da war nämlich da irgendetwas so eine 1Live-Veranstaltung und dann habe ich so ein Filmteam begleitet.
Und da war dann so eine wirklich so eine Ecstasy-Feier, einfach so Techno und alle waren offensichtlich doof und haben Ecstasy genommen.
Und die haben getanzt, wie When Nobody's Watching, tatsächlich. Das war denen völlig scheißegal und es war furchterregend. Wenn, wenn, also Leute, die das Gefühl haben, niemand beobachtet sie, das ist wirklich ein gruseliges Gefühl, weil man denkt, die sind durch, die sind komplett, die sind geisteskrank. Ja. Das bist du, When Nobody's Watching, geisteskrank. Ja, deswegen ist es ja auch eine Kontrollfunktion, Beobachtung. Deswegen ja auch die Fake-Polizei-Autos. Deswegen ja auch die Laptop-Kamera. Du musst gar nicht wirklich beobachtet sein. Ja. Du musst dich nur beobachtet fühlen. Deswegen habe ich meine Laptop-Kamera auch nicht abgeklebt, weil ich nicht sein will, wenn nobody's watching. Ja. Man ist ja auch cooler, wenn somebody's watching. Das stimmt. Es gab neulich so einen Artikel von, also es ist ein FBI-Beitrag, so ein FBI-Artikel, und dann gab es ein Foto aus dem FBI-Büro und alle Laptop-Kameras waren abgeklebt. Ah, holy shit. Vor wem haben die Angst? Ja, vor wem haben die Angst? Ja, die haben ja vor allem Angst. Ja, die wissen ja vor allem, was möglich ist. Ja, oder die haben halt irgendwie so einen Faktastisch-Post gelesen oder sowas und da dachten sich, ja stimmt schon schon. Aber die haben sich Kollegen, der da in der Abteilung arbeitet, geprankt. Das kann auch gut sein, ne? Partplatz-Prank. Du, ich glaube, mit diesem digitalen Zeitalter, da steht uns echt noch was bevor. Echt? Ich wollte gerade die These ausstellen, das ist bald vorbei. Ja, dann haben wir halt zwei unterschiedliche Thesen am Ende des Tages. Kommt auch vor. Ja, ich glaube ist vorbei, weil analog zurückkommt. Die Analog Kamera, der Analog Film. So diese Anhörung von Mark Zuckerberg im Europa-Gedöns gehört? Ausschnittweise, die Memes kenne ich. Wo ich mir auch dachte, ich weiß, das ist ja so eine ambivalente Figur, weiß man nicht, ob der cool ist oder nicht. Mittlerweile ist er so der Bösewicht geworden.
Aber da war dann auch so, wo man sich dann denkt, ist er jetzt für alles verantwortlich, was mit Internet zu tun hat?
Dann eine Abgeordnete hat dann gesagt, ja, es ist ja jemand gestorben wegen Cybermobbing.
Eine Abgeordnete hat sogar gefragt, ich habe das Druckerproblem.
Da heißt Disconnect, aber ich habe jetzt schon mal Connect.
Und die hat gesagt, ja, wegen Cybermobbing bringen sich ja Jugendliche um. Was tun sie dagegen? Und man hat Max Hackerberg angesehen, dass er sich dachte, ja, ist das jetzt mein Scheißproblem? Bin ich jetzt dafür schuld, dass Leute machen? Ich meine, klar, natürlich hat er aufgesprochen und hat gesagt, es ist nicht meine Schuld, dass die Welt... Er hat so einen Erz-Song gesungen, auf Deutsch auch. Ja, ist das jetzt wirklich mein Problem? Ja, wirklich seltsam. Also ich meine, klar, könnte man auf Facebook was machen, dass man dann irgendwie... Aber letztlich ist das ja irgendwie auch ein soziales Problem. Es ist ein vielstichliches Problem, aber dann irgendwie... Das ist nicht sein Problem. Den fertig zu machen, deswegen bin ich keine Ahnung, wie wenn du Gutenberg fertig machst, wenn jemand ein schlechtes Buch rausbringt. Und er so, ja, du hast das doch erfunden. Ja, sorry. Demokratie und alles ist doch völlig hinfällig. Wenn du halt so jemanden hast, der so viel Macht hat durch eine Idee. Ideen sind Macht. Oh, jetzt mag ich es. Nicht Informationen sind Macht. Jetzt mag ich es. Ideen sind Macht. Gibt es einen Tätowierer in der Hörerschaft, der nächste Woche vorbeikommt und Stefan tätowiert? Ich bin, glaube ich, schwach für sowas. Für so einen Impuls-Gag, den man dann kurz lustig findet. Ideen sind Macht. So auf einen kleinen Finger oder sowas. Das so aussieht, als wäre dreckig. Ja, aber das ist doch wirklich interessant, weil der hat quasi ja alle Hebel der Demokratie ausgeschaltet in dem Moment, wo er diese Idee hatte zu Facebook. Weil jetzt plötzlich wird er angehört und muss sich rechtfertigen für so gesellschaftliche Strömungen und sowas und wird dafür verurteilt, nur weil er mal die Idee hatte, Frauen zu vergleichen, wie heiß sie sind. Du bist immer noch bei FaceMatch, ne? Komm, lass es. FaceMatch war 2001 oder sowas. Stefan, du bist in der Vergangenheit, Mann. Ich bin jetzt bei meinem neuen App-Idee, Projekt Enis. Nein, bitte, Stampf, Projekt Enis, das funktioniert nicht. Es funktioniert nicht. Aber ich hätte eine App-Idee, an die ich mal ganz kurz so geglaubt habe, dass ich es nicht im Podcast erzählen wollte. Jetzt erzähle ich sie mal, weil es eh scheisse gerade ist und vielleicht da eh nie zukomme. Napster. Also Projekt Enis basiert nämlich auf der App-Idee. Und das kennt hier jeder, dieses lustige Kennenlern-Icebreaker-Spiel, Tauschen. Du kriegst am Anfang einen Bleistift und einen Apfel, oder die eine Gruppe kriegt einen Bleistift, der andere kriegt einen Apfel, und du tauschst dich hoch. Jetzt ist diese App eine Tausch-App. Du hast einen Gegenstand, und den kannst du einstellen, und du kannst ihn tauschen mit Leuten. Und bist du irgendwann ein Autohass. Und damit wirbt diese App, dass du am Ende Ende, das ist natürlich Quatsch, aber mit In-App-Käufen kannst du dir was Besseres kaufen und so. Kannst du ein Auto kaufen. Kannst du so tun, als hättest du ein Auto. Kannst du dir als In-App-Kauf für 83.000 Euro ein gutes Auto kaufen. Aber das ist eine Tausch-App, wo du mit Leuten tauschen kannst und ins Geschäft kommst. Dir ist schon klar, Stefan, dass vor circa 12.000 Jahren man gesagt hat, du, das mit dem Tauschen ist scheiße, lass uns Geld erfinden. Und seitdem niemand mehr Bock auf Tauschen hat. Ja, man hat gesagt, Analogkameras sind Kacke, lass uns Digitalkameras nehmen. Ja, bei drei Hipster irgendwie sagen, das hat nichts damit zu tun. Und jetzt nach 12.000 Jahren sagt Stefan, nö, die Ägypter waren gar nicht so schlau, jetzt gehen wir wieder zurück zu tauschen. Vergiss tauschen, es ist vorbei. Vorbei. Gut, dann ist Projekt Enis hiermit beendet. Gestorben, das war's. Tschüss, macht's gut, bis nächste Woche, beam up und sagen Tschüss, wir haben uns noch gar nicht vorgestellt, Stefan, Floridin
vielen Dank an Valentin für das fantastische Intro
bis zum nächsten Mal
Valentin, das ist alles falsch ausgesprochen, vielen Dank an Lea für die nette Nachricht
tschau